and I've often thought by the way that
if there were if polish in Romanian and
Bulgarian and another - this country
could compete for the jobs of television
commentators and Guardian new writers
there would be a lot more concern about
than there is but they don't hello and
welcome to trigonometry I'm Frances
Foster I'm Constance thank you sir and
this is the show for you if you're bored
of people arguing on the internet over
subjects a know nothing about and
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic guest this week is a
journalist broadcaster and author Peter
Hitchens welcome to trigonometry well so
far it's pleasure to be well it's great
to have you thank you so much for coming
on we obviously know exactly who you are
that's why we've invited John but for
anyone who who isn't familiar with the
work tell us a little bit about how are
you where you are what's been your
journey okay I'm a I'm a social immoral
conservative I write a weekly column for
the mail on Sunday
I've worked in Fleet Street for more
than 40 years first of all as a reporter
in various subjects from education
politics industry diplomacy and defense
I spent two and a bit years working as
the resident correspondent in Moscow
another two years working as a resident
correspondent in Washington DC I have
traveled on the last count to 57
countries on for work purposes some
which no longer exist I'm the author of
I think seven books but I've changed the
titles of several them so I can't
remember how many of them they're all
very good whatever title there yeah
exactly of course it does and one of the
things we wanted to start by talking
about is you mentioned you a social and
moral conservative and one of the things
you've always been most scathing about
is the transformation of the
conservative party in this country
there's a transformation the
conservative party in this country was
never any good it's always been a
machine for for obtaining office for the
sons of gentlemen that's it's been its
purpose
it's never been conservative but when
for most people I think when when they
hear you talking about say David Cameron
is not a conservative or Teresa may may
not be able to statements of the obvious
so so what what would Peter Hitchens
designed conservative parties well I
wouldn't know because my main purpose in
life for several years I've now given up
politics but when I still tried I made
it my business to try and destroy the
conservative party and to ensure that
it's split and collapsed so that it
could be fed in small pieces down the
plumbing and flushed away into the into
the the laboratory of history but this
this project failed people were far more
interested in voting tribally than they
were in voting rationally and so the
Conservative Party survived under David
Cameron in 2010 when it should have been
wiped for than that and that's when I
decided that really it was futile to try
and get involved in politics it would
only make me unhappy so I just laugh at
it now and so so if if someone else had
been successful in flushing the remains
of the Conservative Party down the
toilet what are the principles that you
talk the moral and social conservatism
I've never understood why we divide
particularly in modern Britain why we
divide politics up the way we do it
seems to me the fundamental division in
modern Western politics is pretty much
summed up in the division between say
the Daily Mail at the Guardian or
between Polly Toynbee and me it's it's
in the moral and social areas of sex
drugs and rock and roll that the main
contentions are nobody cares about the
nationalize in the nationalization of
industry anymore I'm in favor of
nationalizing the railways for instance
but I'm a conservative it's not it's not
an issue the far bigger issue is for
instance whether you have comprehensive
state schools or whether you have
academically selected state schools
which Polly is against and I'm very much
in favor of reintroducing academic
selection the the question of whether we
continue to support in law and custom
the merit family or whether we just say
any old family is fine is also important
and the question of whether we hold
people responsible for their actions or
whether the criminal justice system
basically treats crime as a disease
caused by poverty abuse and all kinds of
other external factors so
the crime isn't the responsibility of
the criminal is another crucial area of
the distinction and these are these are
whether divisions lie but on the other
hand I've never seen why anybody
couldn't be socially conservative on
those issues and also in favor of a
broadly social democratic approach to
things like welfare though of course the
where those two meet it means that you
have a maybe a very strong welfare state
for those who need it but one which is
pretty stringent in not handing out
money to people you don't need is
specifically so that it can be effective
in helping those who really do need help
and that would be my ideal political
party one which was both social
democratic and socially concerned a bit
like what the Labour Party used to be
really until about the middle 50s and
Peter do you think that what is
happening now with the Tory Party with
when they had with the referendum and
David Cameron trying to keep the party
together do you think we're gonna see a
new party rising out I have no idea I
can't read politics anymore I used to I
used to have a pretty broad
understanding of the technicalities of
it of how the parties worked how they
split up and who was who there was a
time when I could give the name of every
member of parliament and his or her
constituency
for memory for instance but now I've
lost it all I can't and also
increasingly I no longer care why do I
ask me I spent some time working in the
in the in the in the parliamentary Lobby
as a political reporter and it was one
of the greatest disappointments in my
life I had worked for years to get in
there I really wanted to do it I thought
it would be some kind of Kingdom of the
mind where intelligent people discussed
the future of the country it turned out
to be a gossip factory and increasingly
a gossip factory manipulated by spin
doctors so that what political reporters
were basically turning out was
regurgitated party propaganda there are
exceptions to this and they're Noble and
and credible but in general political
journalism in this country is a pretty
poor thing and I don't have much left to
do with it so you sound incredibly
almost disillusioned with it I was
disillusioned by that I mean it was
amazing to me to find just how
dull and apolitical the the core of
political journalism was to work in what
was then or what that seemed to me to be
the faded magnificence of the Palace of
Westminster rubbing shoulders with
cabinet nurses and all the rest of it I
had expected to be really really
thrilled and full of enjoyment when I
was doing this and it was nothing with
disappointment so most of what was
discussed was who's up and who's down
who's in and who's out I I now look at
what happened during those years and I
realized that quite major acts of
parliament passed through both houses
apartment at that time without me even
noticing they were going on because we
weren't interested in that but we've
also seen somewhat of a revolt via
brexit against the current political
establishment do you think that signals
a new dawn well you did the other new
doors often bring horrible days don't
they I don't if I think I think that it
did encapsulate some of the things that
are tired for many years been saying
that the the real discontents and the
people were not being reflected by the
political parties and the referendum
released people from party allegiance so
an awful lot of Labour voters who are
socially conservative who don't like the
effects for instance of mass immigration
who don't like the the way in which
their areas have been pretty much
allowed to become the victim areas where
crime and disorder flourish are
unchecked by the police or the courts
there was an enormous great revulsion
there also people at a huge number who
got really really sick of being told
that George Osborne had cured the
economy when he said plainly handin
anybody who didn't actually live in
London knew that but almost nobody who
writes or talks about politics lives
outside London so they had no idea of
just how sick people were of being told
that the recession was over and that
everything was alright and wonderful
when the jobs that people could get were
miserably paid when the cost of housing
was appalling and where almost everybody
was forced to get into debt simply to
live the kind of lives which they had
thought were normal and that also caused
it the the referendum result was it was
a portmanteau
content's all expressed in one thing and
of course I took no part in the
referendum I didn't vote on it as I
don't like referenda I think they're
they're nasty dangerous things and there
was a guy that I predicted if you look
for the worst constitutional crisis in
connection with this you'll probably
find them Express earliest by me in any
index because I thought that would be a
contest between the Democratic mandate
of Parliament and the Democratic mandate
of the referendum and how on earth do
you sort out which is supreme they both
of them have a similar mandate how do
you how do you decide which if they come
into conflict how do you decide who wins
we have no mechanism in our constitution
for deciding this at all this is very
true but on the other hand if you talk
about the fact that many people felt
that they had no way of communicating
and having their concerns validate yes
but if the way that they were given was
a bad way no it isn't because it one of
the worst things about politics
particularly cynical populist politics
designed by public relations man is that
it raises hopes it can't fulfill you can
do that only so many times before you
begin to create really serious
discontent and the election of Donald
Trump and the referendum in this country
both warnings to anybody who cares to
listen that the age of universal
suffrage democracy is coming to a very
dangerous point where people are ceasing
to vote on the basis of if I vote for
this party it will improve my life so if
I vote for this party or vote this way
it will punish people I dislike and when
you move into an area when when
democracy is being used by people to
punish those they dislike and hate then
you move into an area of grave danger
and how if we come to this point but
because of the the ceaseless making
approaches we couldn't keep because of
the delusional attitudes fostered by
both politicians and much of the media
about how important in the case of this
country where how important and rich we
are which we're not and I mean ability
to confront the real problems in this
country and to do anything about that
and always always to change the subject
when they come up so you've said the
real problems of this country Peter what
do you think are the real problems
well the fundamental problem has been I
don't know whether this could have been
avoided
I suspect it largely could have been the
deindustrialization which took place
largely under Margaret Thatcher
unintentionally she never intended to do
it as far as I know but also I think
probably impelled by the membership of
the European Union in the seventies and
eighties has left huge numbers of people
without adequate employment with unable
to do things there that will actually
reward them properly a lesser layer and
enable them to some raise a family and
stable circumstances the education
system was sabotaged by a gas Arian
Dogma in the 1960s the destruction of
academics election in the state system
which lowered the standards of education
for the whole of the country is terribly
visible now the number of people even
who've gone through expensive private
education and have degrees in PPE from
Oxford the number of people who know in
effect almost nothing at all in in
decision-making positions is horrify I
members of parliament can stand up and
say Frances that Britain didn't get any
Marshall aid as a couple of done
recently one at the weekend and how can
anybody become a member of parliament
not knowing that in fact Britain was the
principal recipient of marshal aid to
say that we didn't get it how can such
ignorance possibly not result in in in
the very least incompetence and quite
possibly in disaster in the way the
country and its enterprises and its
institutions around a lot of other
things like you I mean I this is what I
write books about because I think I this
is odd I don't understand why this is so
and so I go off and I do the research
and I've written I've written a book
about the the Cultural Revolution which
swept through the country in the 50s and
60s which for which I was rewarded by
being told that I earned for a return to
the 1950s which has anybody who lived in
the nineteen fifties could tell you I'd
certainly do not do so near a gristle
chillblains cigarette smoke and
[Music]
extraordinary grimace I wouldn't want to
return to it for a moment but nobody
listens to what you say I wrote a book
on what happened about to to crime and
the police against full of research
facts which would be immensely useful to
any Minister tried to do something about
the crime problem I
pressed it into the hands of home
secretaries and chief constables they
never read it
I rigged a lot about the catastrophe
we've helped to the education system
nobody pays any attention at all and it
is extraordinary how there is no
interest in looking at these things why
do you think that is because of the the
national illusion and that's the reason
for my latest book which has has not
been reviewed by any major publication
the phony victory the the national
religion is of the finest hour and
Winston Churchill of Britain's great
role in saving the world and some truth
in this but the trouble is there's an
awful lot of flannel in it as well and
we we comfort ourselves for an episode
in which we actually became much poorer
much less powerful we comfort ourselves
by telling ourselves stories about how
important we were when actually we
weren't and we certainly aren't now and
I think this is the stripping away of
illusionist and this in a way this is
this is not in the way of business I'm a
conservative Christian Patriot for me to
attack a sacred figures such as Winston
Churchill seems to me to be a
significant act and to be educational
for the left to attack it well that's
nothing they've been doing it for years
if somebody if somebody like me does it
then it would seem to me to be
interesting but I can't get anybody to
pay attention but I don't see the
connection between the phony victory as
you call it and chief constables not
wanting to read about the crime
statistic well the connection is in both
cases I've said something important that
nobody wants to know but in the I'm not
I'm not offering your so single cause
for everything I'm just pointing out
that I repeatedly try and and look at
things as they've actually happened to
go into the archives and research what
what took place to see if what were
being told is true and again again I
find what we're told is not true but the
fundamental illusion in this country is
it is an illusion that we have far more
important a far richer than we are in
fact we're terribly in debt both as a
country and as people and military
diplomatic and political power is
physical compare with what it used to be
and it's you're never going to solve the
problems of a country or family or an
individual unless that country or that
family of an individual or an
institution confronts honestly the
difficulties with the country and this
is a thing which was very much the case
for the Soviet Union it was partly
living in the Soviet Union and its final
convulsive months that made me look more
critically at my own country here was an
enormous Empire completely deluding
itself about how rich and strong and
important it was and when it fell the
fool was terrible and you must hurry
because you were in Moscow I think as a
child when I was doing there you must
remember I remember people losing all
their savings overnight standing in the
street selling their possessions from
little from little fake veneer tables
near the markets so they could afford to
eat and these were middle-class
professional people who a couple of
years before and thought their future
was endless and uninterrupted selling
their possessions to live it made a very
strong impression on me it always
reminded me of the opening scenes of
that great film the third man have you
seen it where as which is set in
post-war Vienna and the same thing is
happening
the middle classes of post-war Vienna
are reduced to selling their possessions
on the streets to live a thing I thought
I'd never see anywhere and I saw it in
Moscow and you were talking about crime
do you think that Britain's become a
more dangerous and nor less place I
think very much so for a lot of people
the poorer you are the more dangerous it
is people live in places where they know
perfectly well that there will be no if
their houses are robbed no help will
come the best thing to do is to shut up
you don't want to be known as a grass in
these places because a terrible trouble
will come to you so you don't report the
crime which is why crime statistics best
a little relation to crime as a fact for
a lot of people there is a great deal of
misery they have prairie neighbors and
they have to knuckle up to them and
there is also a great deal more violence
than they used to be and people resort
to violence much more readily than they
used to there's more dangerous
I hold enough to remember the 50s and
while they had many disadvantage
they were extraordinarily peaceful again
it was while I was in Moscow that I was
alerted to this because I used to live
in a rather nice suburb of Portsmouth
called Alistair mainly favored by
retired Admirals in the place an
extraordinary peace and safety where my
brother and I used to roam the streets
as children with in the way that
children used to do on the sunny summer
days and I read you know in a British
newspaper which was delivered to me in
Moscow and a countess for how somebody
had been I think kicked to death in some
stupid meaningless route in in almost oh
I thought well if it's happened there
then we have problems and it did I knew
already it happened elsewhere but for it
to be happening in a place like that I
thought we are a difficulty I've done a
lot of work on the on the fiddling of
crime statistics by the police which was
derided when I did it was late and
vindicated by a House of Commons
committee the the ridiculous claims that
you'll make that violence is falling are
simply not true what's happened is that
recorded violence may be falling the
other thing itself is there are the
Menace of violence which which keeps
people away from places which they were
once who felt safer is also very
important I think the lack of
reassurance as well as a big issue for
example I had my car broken into in
London a few months ago and I had to I
couldn't get through to the police on
the phone I eventually had to report it
online and I got an email back the next
day telling me that the crime couldn't
be investigated because there was no
evidence even though there was CCTV
cameras everywhere that's that that is
that established hundreds of thousands
of people will have had similar
experiences the police having become a
reactive force which waits for crime to
happen and then tries to respond to it
or overwhelmed it is a fundamentally mad
way of trying to deal with crime but
they are absolutely set on doing it and
it can't possibly work it simply creates
more and more demand for services which
are not working and that's why they want
to hear from you online that's why they
closed all the police stations they want
any contact with the public because
anybody bring them trouble and so they
are presumably you got a crime number
for your insurance yeah I got a
but ironically a few weeks later there
was this story that was in the news
recently of Humberside police who called
up a man because he retweeted some
offensive tweet and and they told him
that they needed to check that he was
thinking correctly yes what Twitter is
very is very tightly patrolled I
possibly because it doesn't involve
going around the rain I don't know
saying these things are you are
attacking the police that I love the
police when they are police I think it's
a most fantastic idea to have big guys
in let's not be sexist if big people in
uniform are walking along or even
medium-sized people you know walking
along the street visibly providing a
focus of law and reassurance to
everybody else who who is like it the
effect of a regular preventative foot
patrolling is immense though they won't
do it and it absolutely won't do it they
go on about numbers it's nothing to do
with numbers and this is one of the
things that I discovered in the days
when they used to do regular promoted
foot patrolling there were a lot fewer
of them than there are now so it's not
it's this excuse of numbers which they
always bring out is absolutely false
it's not because they they have the
numbers it's because they don't have the
will and so as you saw from the case
yeah and Peter if you were going to
revolutionize a police force what would
you do what well certain Metis old cars
sell the helicopters sell all that gear
make sure everybody had decent well
fitting boots to walk in and say off you
go I need speed one by one not two by
two if you send police that two by two
this they walk along chatting to each
other about over time and you could
commit a burglary on a night notice but
an individual police officer patrolling
has an enormous effect and just go back
on the beat which is which was abolished
by Roy Jenkins in 1967 and do that and
you'd be amazed
I want to change tack a little if you
don't mind for an sister yeah just to go
back to an issue that you briefly
mentioned which is mass immigration and
the reason I want to bring it up is that
I remember watching you on question time
and you you call that a catastrophe and
the four other panelists would
essentially not let you speak so this is
no episode what we do here so you've
called their catastrophe why is a
catastrophe and you've got plenty of
time tonight a scale of eight
you've got the immigration is is good
generally both for the people who do it
and for the countries which accept it
provided that there's a chance to
integrate when I began in politics long
ago and I was a revolutionary socialist
the thing that we used to talk about was
that we were really really against was
what we called racialism in those days
this was a racial discrimination
it's just distinct an important way from
the word racism that people use now and
one of the things that we very much call
thought was integration no integration
is perfectly possible if someone comes
here as as an individual and and wants
to bring up his children or start a
family or and go to work and all the
things that people do they come from
other countries usually to improve
themselves then in time they will learn
the language they'll learn the customs
the law they will become pretty much
British and no one will only get in
their way in doing so if huge numbers of
people can simultaneously then that
process is impossible what will happen
is that people will gather in areas they
won't integrate they will form solitudes
with their backs turned upon each other
and you will get especially if the state
as it does now encourages
multiculturalism you will get a society
where large parts of you take a city
like Bradford for instance large parts
of the population never meet other parts
of the population except maybe in the
city center crossing and in the crossing
the railroad shops but not in any we
realistically integrator away so mass
emigration
is this damaging because it prevents
integration it's also damaging because
few immigrants are rich they will tend
to come and live in the poorer areas or
cities and they will therefore be
experienced most of all by the poorest
people who are not terribly interested
in the fact that that's a funky new
restaurant around the corner or that you
can hire a nanny as cheaply what they
see is they see in some cases
competition for their jobs and I've
often thought by the way that if there
were if parish in Romanian and Bulgarian
and another migrants this country could
compete for the jobs of television
commentators and Guardian leader writers
there would be a lot more concern than
there is but they don't it's not that
it's in other areas of society where
where it happens and of course also they
put pressure on the housing and on the
on the schools and on the medical
services which means and the transport
which means that everybody is slightly
worse off in a way which they resent and
the other thing is of course that people
don't feel at home in their own areas
and it's all very well sin laughs in the
market bad but I really don't see how
you can't view it as quite a big problem
specially if you're an old person living
alone or where your children have gone
in a small house in a poor area of town
to find bit by bit of the area which you
grew up is no longer recognizable to you
I think that's a serious problem it
hurts people and it's it's not fascist
to be sympathetic towards it or to think
that it would probably be wise to avoid
it and would you blame globalization for
this or is it do you think is there a
particular politician I think there is a
I think there are traces of a policy and
the famous memorandum that Andrew
neither is associated with which I
haven't announced I can't quote from it
but the seem to be a suggestion in what
had come out of New Labour that periods
of heightened Blair ISM that they
actually saw large-scale immigration as
a way of
to rub the Wrights nose rubbing the
rights nose in diversity but I think
even more than that I think they didn't
the New Labour people as I regard them
as euro communist revolutionaries they
didn't like Britain as it was in the
1980s or before that and they wanted to
changes irreversibly and I think they
may well have seen large-scale
migrations our way of doing that and
that's that is after all what happened
there's also another thing governments
for both major parties I think have
decided that they want to turn this into
a low-wage economy so high levels of
employment but low levels of wages as
opposed to what it was before an economy
whether whether there was high hi-pro to
see comparatively high prices in
comparatively high wages that's an
economic decision that requires if it's
to work a large amount of extra labour
coming into the country and that means
immigration I think they've actually
been although they make speeches saying
we're going to get it under control one
day and bring it down to whatever level
it is per year I think actually what
they've had in mind what their economic
you can like advise us and tell them is
that they should they should if not
actually actually encouraged certainly
be perfectly happy to accept a fairly
constantly high level of migration of
young men and women who who will fill
these low-wage jobs if they do but
there's a very easy way to shut down
that debate that somebody voices your
opinions and I'm here listening to them
go well this is all perfectly reasonable
is from the other person to shout well
you're racist and they do but I can't
the only the only answer I can give use
of that is that you'd have to provide
some sort of some sort of justification
for making the claim as I say I used to
be a revolution revolutionary socialist
the best thing about the far left in
this country
always was it's absolute opposition to
racial bigotry it's a it's a point that
I've I've never diverged from it all my
changes of political positions since
then I've never changed my view racial
bigotry is disgusting and I'm against it
if you don't like it I think one of the
things you might need to do is to
consider whether large-scale immigration
actually makes racial bigotry more or
less likely I suspect
that it could make it more like
[Music]
completer moving on one thing of always
from very interesting reading your
columns is your absolute opposition to
the legalization of marijuana and
because there is at the moment there's a
bit of a movement it combined with you
know the pharmaceutical companies with
medicine medicinal marijuana to legalize
it why are you so opposed to it well
that's pretty lowest level you the
legalization of a drug is a reversible
once you legalize anything that and it
becomes legal and then goes it goes into
mass use you will not be able to to
prohibit it again officer give you an
example the Iranian Islamic Republic's
attempt to suppress alcohol now the
Islamic Republic is a pretty despotic
state I could throw you into prison has
happened to my friend Jason rezaian on
no pretext at all and coolly what it
likes and you have no protection I has
huge resources and no doubt plenty of
people who can influence by and since
1979 has tried to ban alcohol in the
Islamic Republic of Iran it is
completely and utterly failed I didn't
do it when I was on a visit there but I
believe my brother went here did you can
order alcohol in Tehran and within half
an hour it will be delivered to your
door
there's no difficulty you can't you
can't once you've once you've legalized
something you can't they're demon so
it's an irreversible step just at the
moment when more and more information is
coming out that the use of marijuana is
is correlated with and I stress that the
correlation it's correlated with quite
severe mental illness and I would cite
particularly the Swedish army study and
the Dunedin study which suggests this
and also the work of Professor Sir Robin
Murray and that moment when the
information is just beginning to come it
would seem to be the worst possible name
to take an irreversible step that's
putting it at its absolute gentlest I
would say that you could go
further there is a website called
attacker smoked cannabis which I commend
to anybody which just lists the
astonishing number of cases in which
people have committed acts of savage
violence after smoking cannabis or
people with the cannabis have it
I myself have looked into this is not
about terrorism everybody so Hitchens is
trying to excuse his Lomb Hitchens says
it's not that there's no jihad this is
round objects I mean it's such rubbish
but people will say it but so I have to
put in that caveat I looked into the
because because the information wasn't
there I looked into all the major
terrorist incidents in Europe and all
the major rampage killings in North
America and indeed Japan in in recent
years and the reason I could look into
them was because unlike most crime these
episodes are still thoroughly covered by
the media people actually do look into
the antecedents of the of the
perpetrators in a way which in lots of
cases they simply don't and what I found
was that in almost every single case the
perpetrators of these rampage killings
whether in North America or Europe or
Britain from the killers of Lee Rigby -
it's a giant lock know the man who
massacred people in Arizona - the
killers of two Canadian soldiers - the
batter clan killers - the guy who was
who killed people on the beach in Ch in
his ear at soos - the man who who pulled
a gun on the passengers in the Telus
train every single one of them was a
marijuana user there are other drugs
involved as well Anders Breivik for
instance through his own testimony we
know this and as brennick was on
steroids as was there on my team the
culprits of the of the orlando and
nightclub killing and indeed the
culprits of the westminster knife attack
and the London Bridge so steroids are
important as well and so our
antidepressants but marijuana plays a
very very large role in these things and
in the backgrounds of many many people
who commit serious acts and violence it
is there it's not there because they
were they were necessarily stand at the
time it's there because of its long-term
effects on people if you look if you
look at the good at the behavior of
bellagio inaudible Ally the two killers
of Lee Rigby in court you can see that
these were people who were not wholly
how shall I say not wholly reasonable
and Peter would you therefore have it
upgraded to a class a from the class P I
think these distinctions are more or
less mean it's the distinction the a B
and C distinctions were invented for the
1971 misuse of Drugs Act I've written
about this in detail in in my book the
war we never fought the two things the
the marijuana legalization campaign has
wanted one was to separate marijuana
from the other bogeymen drugs at the
time and at the time they were LSD and
heroin and so the classification of a
and B separated that the other thing
they wanted to do is to separate the
crime of possession from the crime of
sale and trafficking to make possession
a minor crime and trafficking a major
crime there's no logic in this if you
think about it and they achieved both of
those things it's nice to do it Class A
or Class B you can classify this class
double xzh if you don't actually
prosecute which is what we don't do then
you will have no effect and what happens
at the moment is we have a law because
we're obliged most national treaty to
have that law but we don't operate it so
the actually act a very serious crime
which attracts a a prison sentence of
five years and an unlimited find of
possession of cannabis is pretty much
unprosecuted the police were as far as
they possibly can avoid arresting
anybody for if they do arrest them for
it they'll probably give them something
called the cannabis warning which is
meaningless if they ever are prosecuted
the the courts will will hand down the
tiniest conceivable sentence it's a law
we know for what about changing from A
to B is is a meaningless gesture policy
what about the kind of Portuguese model
where you decriminalize and treat as a
health issue rather than as a crime
issue well again i have to direct you
because this we could spend hours on
this - a long blog posting which i wrote
on the portuguese drug paradise portugal
had a very serious story
problem before these these changes were
made it didn't actually and the
enforcement of drug law in Portugal
before there have been extremely weak
the changes claimed are perhaps an
exaggerated and may be wrongly
attributed the for instance the
Portugal's and needle exchange program
and various other things go back a long
time of volunteer utilization and some
things have got worse particularly
lifetime use of certain drugs and I
would say that I would say this is a
correlation and not a causation that
homicide and petty crime also increased
there are many aspects to drug abuse
apart from the deaths of drug users
which we have to worry about one of them
is the mental health security of users
of cannabis which is is seldom recorded
because most modern Western countries
try as hard as they possibly can
not to get involved in treating the
mentally ill because it's so expensive
so they just shut them to one side then
you have the difficulty of crime
committed by people who mutating drugs
which by and large police don't record
or pay any attention to and then you
have the the the the the general level
of other crime which tends to follow
where drugs come first and I think a
serious examination of Portugal i I've
tried to put to examine both sides of
the case in this long I've written about
it a serious examination now it shows
that it's by no means the paradise
that's claimed and people should look at
it more carefully before before
imagining and somehow or other they've
solved the problem in Lisbon because
they have not and Peter where do you
stand on the issue of addiction do you
believe that it's a mental health
condition or do you think it's an
indulgence
it's a fantasy there is no such thing I
the word has no definable meaning it's a
shapeshifter and this is the problem
with it people will use it in two
distinct ways they will use it as if it
excuses the drug user from from taking
the drug there's a totally overwhelms
his or her will so that he has no choice
but to take it and they will use it in
another way to suggest the opposite it
cannot be both either you can stop or
you cannot stop in my view you can and
many people do and
think the treating of what is
effectively a crime as an illness is
very dangerous I it's also rather
insulting to people were genuinely ill I
no one no one no one voluntarily gets
cancer no one voluntarily gets the
leukemia no one voluntarily gets
tuberculosis these are illnesses these
can be treated people who start taking
powerful psychotropic illegal drugs do
it as an active voluntary will and also
they don't become habituated which is as
far as I prepared together and become
habituated immediately it could take
quite a LeFort to get habituated to any
drug
these people should not be treated as if
they were ill they should be treated as
if they are voluntary criminals and and
and if we did that I promised you we'd
have a lot fewer of them and if you
really are seriously concerned about the
suffering which is caused by these drugs
both to the people who take them and to
their families and to their neighbors
and to their workmates and to the and to
the taxpayers who who who get mugs to
give them their methadone if you're
seriously concerned about all these
things then you should be trying to
prevent people becoming a bit feel drug
users and I think a judicious
application of the criminal law would be
a much better way of doing that than the
amount of so-called treatment and there
are people who would say that the fact
that we decided that we decide to make
marijuana illegal but alcohol legal is
incredibly hypocritical when actually
alcohol is incredibly dangerous
dangerous and and but again we have the
problem it is already legal and as use
an attempt to ban it would no way in in
a free country such as this one the the
measures that you would have to take
even to try would be would be
politically impossible that doesn't mean
that alcohols shouldn't be more tightly
controlled I very much regret the repeal
of the the very effective alcohol
licensing laws which were in place in my
childhood in my teens which were
abolished by mainly by the Conservative
Party in the 1980s when pubs were open
and for areas noted parts of the day and
when it was you couldn't buy alcohol and
supermarkets turn off licences and in
general it was much harder to get not
impossible much harder
not much less drinking I would bring
that by like it's short but I can't see
how the existence of one disastrous
legal poison in our society you know and
the existence of another disastrous
legal poison in the shape of cigarettes
could possibly be an argument for
introducing a third legal poison into
our society it doesn't seem to me that
there's any logic in that that could be
advanced by anybody who wasn't [ __ ]
[Music]
well on that happy note
let's move on and I wanted we wanted to
talk to us we were talking before we
started recording about me being from
the Soviet Union Francis mother from
Venezuela III you troubled as a former
revolutionary socialist by the seeming
resurgence of some of those ideas in in
our society I've never troubled by yes I
know people are entitled to have ideas
it's it's right for people I would much
rather for someone to be profoundly
discontented about our society than it
is for him to stupefy himself with drugs
for instance at least at least of some
thoughts and some energy some revulsion
against injustice and this isn't this is
an unjust world and anybody who doesn't
notice that is is incredibly observant
and flaccid and passionately no I
wouldn't
I'd never object to to strongly-held
genuinely held political opinions
critical of things as they are it would
be wrong if people if people didn't hold
I also be betraying my own self if i if
i said oh well i was allowed to be a
revolutionary when i was in my teens and
twenties in your nods and objection of
people all the ideas no but I think they
should test them against practice and I
think they should also test them against
history and they might find that some of
them have very dangerous consequences my
my fundamental rule about this is the
problem with utopia is that it can only
ever be approached across a sea of blood
and you never get that and those my
warnings or anybody who thinks that he
can create utopia well I agree with you
in the it's great that people are
exploring ideas but some ideas are very
bad ideas lots of ideas are very bad and
almost always that need to be needs to
be tempered in moderate
by experience in restraint which is
which is why sensible societies make
sure that the power is surrounded by a
bodyguard of muttering pessimist saying
well I don't know about that Italy the
law which Parliament passes every day is
the law of unintended consequences and
if I were reordering Parliament I would
set up a select committee on unintended
consequences to be given the job of
evaluating every major piece of
legislation to look for unintended
consequences because there are so many
of them and they are actually often
avoidable imagine if we had that before
breaks it was that wasn't legislation
that's here's the whole point that was
direct democracy yeah and it's one of
the reasons I'm there is one country in
continental Europe which absolutely does
not hold referenda which is it in Europe
yeah it doesn't hold referenda it's the
Federal Republic of Germany and that's
because of hard historical experience
they know how these things are seen
people it's it's a living memory of
house of how this this this can be
misused and they don't they don't know
words I'm with them if you if you have a
parliamentary democracy you you you
don't want to mix it up with direct
democracy which apart from everything
else
removes all the mediating factors so
that's why I was against the referendum
and that's why I didn't version it and
I'm increasingly regarded as a sort of
remain a traitor by people who in the
long lonely years when I was a near
solitary believer in secession from the
European Union were nowhere to be seen
and they now shouting and screaming at
me as if I could trade it because I'm
not keen on what's going on now I want
to stick with the left just for a moment
though because the reason I asked about
it is it seems to me that there's a you
know in your days when you were a
radical revolutionary the the left
talked about workers and oppressors
we've got past that we wouldn't buy lot
would have we got thought of ourselves
as a reasonably literate and educated we
wouldn't have talked that kind of
language which we did believe that the
the main engine of revolution would come
from what then still existed in this
country which is an industrial working
class and we spent an awful lot of our
time by trying to recruit from the
industrial working class and in the
trade union movement it was the the
primer activity that we had and sounded
quite successful but of course that's
gone there yeah so that's my point which
is the left has now gone to this
identity politics thing where it's
created a whole different structure of
oppressors and the oppressed and it's
actually you talked about racial
discrimination it seems to be putting
some of those elements almost in Reverse
well it gets into terrible messes
particularly over Islam that the the
left will sometimes identify with Islam
cause this is a great deal of the labor
parties problem with with what is cool
that he semitism it's more complicated
than that but the there is a great deal
of of shyness about criticizing some of
the more virulent attitudes of some
Muslims and particularly towards the
State of Israel
and that's one of the reasons for that
and also of course the the the almost
ridiculous Alliance which the Socialist
Workers Party the successor of the
organization to which I belong got into
a over Islam Islam being fantastically
morally conservative and the swp not
being enough to hold hands for some time
this is this is unprincipled stuff but
there is a the the turn away from trying
to achieve a working class revolution
which is fundamentally a
nineteenth-century idea came a lot of
earlier than the nineteen nineties it
goes back titania Graham she in the 1922
the first of the European communists
were realized that the Soviet experiment
was already a disaster that the the
Soviet seizure of power would never be
replicated in advanced European
countries where you had an educated
largely Christian working class then a
Cultural Revolution as a change in
hegemony was the thing needs to be
achieved and that the the issues that
where the battle would have to be held
would would not necessarily be you know
cultural and moral the destruction
particularly of the of the power of the
Christian Church being part of it and
there is a inevitable hostility between
between revolution Christianity which
shows all the time and that's which
began by Graham she more or less
discovered by us when we were student
revolutionaries in the late sixties and
early seventies and then brought into
practice by the long march to the
institutions of the university
generation which then rose the immense
number of people in Blair's cabinet who
had been a revolutionary socialists in
one kind or another including Blair
himself who recently confessed it a fact
we almost nobody knows because nobody
understands its significance but if it
had have it had come out in 1995
wouldn't destroyed him but the these
people are not like me I was a
Trotskyist I openly ser was a trustee as
most people know was the transcripts
because I've told them the the members
of the Blair's cabinet who were
trotskyists don't publicize it don't
talk about it don't like discussing it
because it's still important to them
it's still important part of their
political formation and they are modern
intelligent revolutionists you realized
that that's using the post office and
the barracks as a railway station isn't
the thing anymore what you see now is
the television studio of the University
and the school and the newspaper and and
and indeed the the courts and that's
what they they did they went they came
out of university at the end of the the
end of the sixties and they found out
into all these things and they simply
became they became the layer of
professional people who were doing all
things and they became immensely
influential and by 1997 they really
couldn't understand why they weren't
also the government which is which is
where there's a sort of explosion of
righteous righteous joy among them when
the Blair government was elected finally
we're not just empower in the
universities and the courts and the BBC
we're empower and the government we've
got Downing Street to and
mence revolutionary moment probably the
most revolutionary moment since Cromwell
and people still don't get it
and with regards to Corbin do you think
he's going to be seen as a successful
lady Libra or do you think he's gonna be
seen as someone who's blown a major
opportunity I don't know it depends what
happens he's it was it was always sort
of John Major that he became everything
he became I not being somebody he became
he became prime minister by not being
Myra thatcher he stayed prime minister
by not being neil kiddo and then he lost
his job by not being Tony Blair and but
jeremy corbyn's case all his all his
advantages and negative if he's faced by
a conservative party and a terrible mess
with a pretty disastrous leader he might
I wouldn't rule out the possibility
certainly of a for instance of a Corey
night Labor Scottish nationalists
arrangement of government of majority in
part at some time in the future is
perfectly possible that he could become
realist and very interesting to watch
and see how that works out and who the
important people are in that government
I would call it probably won't be one of
the corners fundamentally like to resume
a local government person that's where
he comes from from the the Backstairs of
town halls spend a lot of time as a way
in in local government before she rose
without Trish to where she is now and
the that is narrow poorly educated not
particularly articulate person I believe
he reads books for instance I don't
think that he's really capable of the of
the breadth of understanding we should
make him a particularly effective prime
minister whether you like what he did or
not but I want maybe people like John
McDonnell rather might be rather more
important in his government that he is
if there is such a government but I
don't know I can't tell but in political
terms Jeremy Coleman is a museum piece
he's a he's he's a relic of a kind of
left-wing politics which I remember
still existing when I was in the London
neighborhood parties in the in the late
nineteen seventies early nineteen
eighties but which is long ago was
superseded by the
the new label grabs you and cultural
revolutionaries and they're there almost
touching the honest in there obviously
they're obviously on the far left and
they they're open about it whereas the
Blair i'ts pretended to be conservatives
and they still do in some ways I would
rather have my my enemy in plain sight
saying what he actually is then there's
the Blair rights to pretending to be
something they are well that secure a
thing as you talk about this being one
of the greatest revolution in 1997 97
was it was it was a huge revolution but
the Labour Party under Corbin has gone
further to the left no it's a different
left it's it's it's either sort of
Edwardian leftist he still thinks you
know in all this in all those categories
one of the reasons why he's he's against
the European Union because the European
Union is of course a cultural
revolutionary project it's very secular
it's it's very opposed to national
sovereignty it's a supranational all
it's all its social attitudes are
liberal and politically correct too and
it's an extreme most extreme level many
of the big major social and moral
changes that have been imposed on this
country by law in the past ten years
actually started life as European Union
directives and it's a revolution one of
the founders of Europeanism as we know
it now is LTRO Spinelli and another
Italian Communist who I absolutely knew
that was very familiar with the work of
Antonia grouchy
so so to be against the European Union
is to be a very old-fashioned almost the
pre 1917 type of leftist I say he's a
museum piece but museum pieces can be
got out of museums and they too well
we're running out of time and Peter
normally we ask some our guests what's
the one thing no one's talking about
that we ought to be talking about I have
a sense that with you there might be a
couple of things so why don't you well I
there are lots of thing I would have I
would certainly have talked about the
the the cannabis issue if we hadn't
already done so it isn't talked about
anything like enough and the the
correlation between cannabis use and
mental health cannot be talked about
enough because it's and the correct the
correlation between cannabis use and
crime can't be talked about enough but
their major problems I'm pursuing a
petition on this matter at the moment to
try and get the governor to inquire into
the link to see if it is not just a
correlation with a genuine causal
connection but the other thing that
always preoccupies me in his preoccupied
me since my childhood is the horrible
way in which we allow the car to
dominate our civilization it's have
chosen to make it that the dominant
means of transport and will not turn
away from this even now near where I
live in Oxford the supplanting yet
another motorway called the Oxford
Cambridge Expressway which will be a
horrible scar across the face of the
country will solve no problems but is
based upon this this love of an
obsession with the cars that was the
only modern means of transport we're
prepared to give serious support to
which does so much damage to health to
to the beauty of the country to town
planning so the way in which people live
and in deeds of the freedom of children
to roam about the countryside it's the
car it's not it's not paedophile killers
they are they exist and when they and
when they happen they're terrible things
and I'm not laughing about that they do
exist but it's very rare but the real
danger the real reason why children
can't roam about is that when I was
young it's because the roads are just
too dangerous
and we just tolerate this and the large
numbers of deaths and terrible injuries
every year wholly innocent people in
nobody cares I really do wish people
cared more about it it's it's a it's
it's it's done a great deal of damage
and we could do a lot more to restrain
it do you think without wood that would
be the case we could we could do more to
restrain if the public transport system
was better well in Zurich in Switzerland
is a paradise of railways and public
transport you can get anywhere without a
car in Switzerland they minzer if they
made the tram system so good that people
gave up driving the Mercedes I want that
to happen here I want the public transit
system to be so good that people don't
use cars I think it would be a huge
improvement thank you very much Peter if
people want to find you on Twitter where
can they find you well I had said I
can't explain this but my twitter handle
is Clark my curse is which is the name
of the favorite novel
backwards if I can't really explain why
it is that you can't I can't certainly
use my own name but believe me I haven't
deliberately to confuse you but if you
search would be the agency will put will
put it in the video will put in the
video thank you so much for coming on
it's been a pleasure speaking with you
and as always follow us at trigger pod
on twitter facebook instagram and
obviously subscribe to the YouTube
channel as many of you already have
click that Bell button there so
subscribe button and we will see you in
a week from now and also if you enjoying
the podcast please share it please tell
a friend leave us a review on iTunes
we're up to 35 now and we're slowly
building so please leave us a nice
review and we will see you next week
thank you very much
[Music]